This is episode 6 of Not Built For This, Maximum Temperature. Last summer, temperatures in Phoenix, Arizona got above 110 degrees for more than 30 days in a row. A couple of times in July, the thermometer nearly cracked 120. It is always hot in Phoenix in the summertime, but this was a new and unwelcome record. And as the city endured this string of unbearably hot days, there was this one image that I became fixated on. All right, check this out. Even the saguaros here in the valley can't take the heat anymore.
这里是《不适于此》第六集：《最高气温》。去年夏天，亚利桑那州凤凰城的温度连续30多天超过110华氏度（约43.3摄氏度）。在7月的几次极端天气中，温度计几乎爆表，直逼120华氏度（约48.9摄氏度）。凤凰城的夏天向来炎热，但这创下了令人不安的新纪录。正当这座城市忍受着这一连串热得令人窒息的日子时，有一个画面深深吸引了我的注意。好吧，瞧瞧这个。连山谷里的巨人柱仙人掌也再也经受不住这酷热了。
It's become a summer trend that just won't seem to stop. Our beloved saguaros toppling to the ground and it's leaving many neighbors— All across the city, saguaros were keeling over in the heat. These massive, stately cacti can grow up to 60 feet tall and weigh thousands of pounds. And they were coming down left and right, crushing cars and denting roofs. I just started hearing a loud crack. So I looked up and I just saw the cactus falling over. A good amount of the roof, like the drywall, fell off. Our next-door neighbors thought it was like a minor earthquake.
这已经成了一种挥之不去的夏季趋势。我们深爱的巨人柱仙人掌纷纷倒地，这让许多居民——在全城各地，巨人柱在酷热中成批地倒下。这些巨大、庄严的仙人掌可以长到60英尺（约18米）高，重达数千磅。它们接二连三地倒塌，压坏了汽车，砸凹了屋顶。我只听到一声巨响。所以我抬头一看，就看见仙人掌倒了下来。很大一部分屋顶，比如干墙，都掉了下来。我们的邻居还以为发生了小型地震。
The saguaro is a master of desert survival. There's literally nothing about its physical being, from its waxy skin to its spongy interiors, that isn't adapted to Arizona's furnace blast temperatures. And yet here they were, dying. Well, I thought it would outlive me by a hundred years. It seemed like a pretty ominous sign. If the saguaros couldn't survive in the heat, what did it mean for us?
巨人柱是沙漠生存的大师。从它打蜡的表皮到海绵状的内部，它的生理结构无一不适应亚利桑那州如炼狱般的极端高温。然而它们却在这里死去。嗯，我曾以为它能比我多活一百年。这似乎是一个非常不祥的征兆。如果连巨人柱都在酷热中无法生存，那对我们意味着什么？
I first got interested in heat in Phoenix. I had been covering climate change for 20 years and didn't give heat much thought, as strange as that may seem. This is the climate writer Jeff Goodell. He's the author of the book The Heat Will Kill You First. And he got interested in heat when he was in downtown Phoenix in the middle of summer and decided to walk 20 blocks to a meeting. Rookie move. I mean it was like walking into a kind of solid wall of this invisible force
我最初对凤凰城的酷热产生兴趣时，我已经报道气候变化20年了，却对热浪不怎么关注，听起来可能有点奇怪。这是气候作家杰夫·古德尔（Jeff Goodell）。他是《热浪杀机》（The Heat Will Kill You First）一书的作者。他对热浪产生兴趣，是因为有一次他在盛夏时节来到凤凰城市中心，决定步行20个街区去开会。初来乍到的蠢行。我的意思是，那感觉就像是走进了一堵由无形力量构成的坚固墙壁，
that just surrounds you and envelops you and kind of suffocates you and makes your body, I mean the only word I can use to kind of describe it is freak out. And by the time I got to my meeting I was dizzy, my heart was pounding and I was a little off balance. And I realized, oh my gosh, heat is dangerous. If I had to go another 20 blocks, I don't know if I would make it. So for me, that was the beginning of everything. Specifically, the beginning of Jeff trying to understand
它包围着你、包裹着你、几乎让你窒息，让你的身体——我的意思是，我能用来形容它的唯一词汇就是“崩溃”。当我到达开会地点时，我已经头晕目眩，心跳加速，甚至有点站不稳了。我意识到，天哪，热浪太危险了。如果我再走20个街区，我不知道自己还能不能坚持下来。所以对我来说，那就是一切的开始。具体来说，是杰夫开始试图理解
what climate change will mean for us on a physiological level. The impacts of climate disasters are often assessed in terms of property damage. When a hurricane hits a place like Florida, the news shows images of gas stations ripped open like tin cans, homes flattened by the wind, cars floating down a flooded main street. We talk about the millions of dollars of damage. But in places like Phoenix and in hot places all over the world,
气候变化将在生理层面上对我们意味着什么。气候灾难的影响通常是用财产损失来评估的。当飓风袭击佛罗里达等地时，新闻画面中会出现被撕裂得像易拉罐一样的加油站、被风夷为平地的房屋、在被淹没的主干道上漂浮的汽车。我们讨论的是数百万美元的损失。但在凤凰城以及世界各地的炎热地区，
climate change is wreaking a very different kind of havoc. On living things. On people's bodies. Heat kills more people every year than any other weather event. The best estimate on the annual death toll is around 500,000 people globally, but that's almost certainly an undercount. And yet, even as we're freaking out about our warming world, many of us still don't really think about heat itself as an existential threat. And I think that's at
气候变化正在造成一种截然不同的破坏。对生物的破坏。对人类身体的破坏。每年死于酷热的人数超过任何其他天气事件。据对全球年度死亡人数的最佳估计，大约为50万人，但这几乎可以肯定是保守估计。然而，尽管我们对不断变暖的世界感到惊慌失措，许多人仍然没有真正将热浪本身视为一种生存威胁。我认为这
least in part because of the language that we used for many years to describe this crisis. The phrase global warming doesn't not sound very alarming. It sounds like maybe we should get our beach chairs and go to the beach. It sounds like time for shorts and flip-flops. In other words, if our global temperatures increase by, say, a few degrees, is that really something to get all bent out of shape about? No, it doesn't sound dangerous at all. It just sounds like, you know, I have other bigger problems to worry about than whether
至少部分是因为我们多年来用来描述这场危机的语言。全球变暖（global warming）这个词听起来并不那么令人担忧。它听起来可能像是我们该拿上沙滩椅去海滩了。听起来像是穿短裤和人字拖的时候了。换句话说，如果我们全球的气温上升，比如说几度，这真的是一件值得大惊小怪的事吗？不，听起来一点也不危险。听起来就像是，你知道的，我还有其他更大的问题要操心，而不是
it's 78 or 80 degrees outside. But a few degrees do matter. Last year, 2023, was the hottest year ever recorded in human history. The last time the world was this hot was 125,000 years ago. And as we build on a hotter baseline, heat waves also get more extreme and more deadly. Phoenix, Arizona has the dubious distinction of being the hottest major city in America. And it's perhaps the best place in the country to investigate our confused relationship with heat and its effects on our health. It's a place that's marketed itself as a warm and pleasant escape from the snowbound north.
外面是78度还是80度。但几度确实至关重要。去年，即2023年，是人类有记录以来最热的一年。上一次世界这么热还是在12.5万年前。随着我们在一个更热的基准线上不断刷新纪录，热浪也变得更加极端、更加致命。亚利桑那州的凤凰城有一个令人尴尬的“荣誉”——它是美国最热的大城市。它也许是全国审视我们对热及其对健康影响的混淆关系的绝佳地点。这个地方把自己营销为一个摆脱北方冰雪的温暖宜人避难所。
But now there are people in the Valley of the Sun looking at these warming trends, and they're worried. As Phoenix continues to grow, with thousands of new residents arriving every year, there are advocates pushing the city and even the federal government to recognize extreme heat for what it is. A force that is testing our biological limits. Because our bodies were not built for this. This is the final episode in our series.
但现在，太阳谷（Valley of the Sun）的人们正看着这些变暖的趋势，他们感到担忧。随着凤凰城的不断发展，每年都有成千上万的新居民涌入，一些倡导者正在推动市政府甚至联邦政府正视极端热浪的真面目——一种正在考验我们生理极限的力量。因为我们的身体并非为此而生。这是我们系列的最后一集。
I'm Emmett Fitzgerald. 99PI senior editor Delaney Hall is also our in-house desert correspondent. She lives in New Mexico. And last year, she made a trip to Phoenix to try and understand how heat went from being the city's number one selling point to a public health crisis. Last summer, on a 100 degree day, I went out driving around Phoenix with a guy named Sergio Armandades. So, are we going to some Circle Ks? Yeah, we have a list here of store addresses.
我是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）。99PI的高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）也是我们的内部沙漠通讯员。她住在新墨西哥州。去年，她前往凤凰城，试图了解热浪是如何从该市最大的卖点变成一场公共卫生危机的。去年夏天，在一个100华氏度（约37.8摄氏度）的日子里，我跟着一个名叫塞尔吉奥·阿尔曼达斯（Sergio Armandades）的男子开车在凤凰城四处转悠。所以，我们要去一些Circle K便利店吗？是的，我们这里有一份店铺地址清单。
I'll check in with the manager and I'll let him know that I'm here doing outreach. Sergio does street outreach with the Phoenix Rescue Mission. It's an organization that works with homeless people in Phoenix. And today I'm tagging along with him while he hits up a number of convenience stores. And is there a reason people kind of tend to group around the circle case? Like what's going on there from a homeless person's perspective? You know, on a hot day, you can grab a bunch of ice and grab some soda.
我会去跟经理打个招呼，让他们知道我来这里做外展服务。塞尔吉奥在“凤凰城救援使命”（Phoenix Rescue Mission）从事街头外展工作。这是一个为凤凰城无家可归者提供服务的组织。今天我跟着他一起走访了多家便利店。人们倾向于聚集在Circle K周围有什么原因吗？从无家可归者的角度来看，那里的情况是怎样的？你知道的，在炎热的日子里，你可以拿一堆冰块，再弄点苏打水。
You know, it's pretty cheap. Polar pops is my favorite thing. So if you got food stamps, you can go get some quick food real quick, you know? It's like turning into a Circle K advertisement. I love it. I love it. food real quick, you know. It's like turning into a Circle K advertisement. The city of Phoenix is trying all sorts of ways to make itself cooler as the planet heats up. They're painting streets with reflective coating to repel the sun,
你知道，这挺便宜的。北极泡泡冰（Polar pops）是我的最爱。所以如果你有食品券，你就可以马上去买点快餐，你知道的？这快变成Circle K的广告了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。快餐，你知道的。这快变成Circle K的广告了。随着地球变暖，凤凰城市政府正在尝试各种方法让自己降温。他们在街道上涂上反光涂层来反射阳光，
they're planting lots of trees, and they're building out a network of cooling centers where people can go hang out during the heat of the day. They've even got a new heat czar whose job is to help cool the city down. But when it comes to saving lives during the hottest summer in history, at least the hottest one so far, it's hard to imagine anyone with a more important job than Sergio. We're gonna go get some ice. I think it's important that I have some cold water. It's a good icebreaker. No pun intended, right?
他们种植了大量树木，并正在建立一个降温中心网络，供人们在白天的酷热时段前往休憩。他们甚至有了一位新的“热浪沙皇”（heat czar），其职责就是帮助这座城市降温。但当谈到在有史以来最热的夏天——至少是迄今为止最热的夏天——拯救生命时，很难想象还有谁的工作比塞尔吉奥更重要。我们要去弄点冰块。我觉得随身带点冷水很重要。这是一个很好的破冰方式。双关语，不是吗？
Sergio is a remarkably chill guy. He drives all over the city, cranking the AC, cracking jokes, and talking about Jesus. But his work also has high stakes. Every summer, hundreds of people in Phoenix die from the heat, and many of them are homeless. Sergio knows firsthand how hard it can be to survive when you have nowhere to go to escape the heat.
塞尔吉奥是一个非常随和的人。他开车穿梭于全城，开着强劲的空调，开着玩笑，谈论着耶稣。但他的工作也面临着巨大的风险。每年夏天，凤凰城都有数百人死于酷热，其中许多人是无家可归者。塞尔吉奥深知，当无处可去以躲避酷热时，生存是多么艰难。
I've slept at this park before. He did it himself for five years. My stomping grounds weren't too far from here. And now he works in a lot of the same neighborhoods where he once camped or hung out or spent hours looking for scraps of shade. When we pull up at the Circle K, there are a couple people hanging out at the side of the store. Sergio approaches a man to see about getting him into a shelter for the night, while I
我以前在这个公园睡过。他自己曾露宿街头五年。我以前的活动范围离这儿不远。现在他在许多曾经露宿、闲逛或花几个小时寻找阴凉之地的街区工作。当我们把车停在Circle K旁时，有几个人在店侧面闲逛。塞尔吉奥走近一个男子，看能否安排他当晚入住庇护所，而我
sit and talk with a middle-aged woman. She has a repurposed baby stroller packed full of her stuff, including a cute scruffy little dog. What's that little guy's name? That's Cupacabra. Hey, he goes nuts when he sees another dog. This is Bunny. She came to Phoenix in 1986 and then says that she got stuck.
坐下来与一位中年妇女交谈。她有一个改装过的婴儿车，里面塞满了她的东西，还有一只可爱、毛茸茸的小狗。那只小家伙叫什么名字？那是丘帕卡布拉（Chupacabra）。嘿，他一看到别的狗就发疯。这是邦尼（Bunny）。她于1986年来到凤凰城，然后说自己被困在这里了。
She's been living here for almost 40 years, homeless on and off, and so by now she's developed a lot of tricks for beating the heat. She carries an umbrella, she wears a rag dipped in cold water around her neck, and she makes sure she stays hydrated. You know, all we can do is try to find a shady spot to sit if the cops don't run us out. Most times, we're stuck out in the sun. It really sucks,
她在这里断断续续地流浪了近40年，所以到现在她已经摸索出了许多对抗酷热的绝招。她随身携带雨伞，脖子上围着一块浸过冷水的抹布，并确保自己补充足够的水分。你知道的，我们能做的就是尽量找个阴凉的地方坐坐，如果警察没有把我们赶走的话。大多数时候，我们只能呆在太阳底下。这真的很糟糕，
because there's nowhere out there to really cool down. It's hot, nasty, muggy, dirty, filthy, just all around bad news. You know, I feel like Arizona has this thing where people come because they love the sun and they love the life here. Have you found that or? I've found a few people that like it, yeah. But there's very few of them that like it whenever it hits 120, 125.
因为外面根本没有地方可以真正凉快下来。天气又热、又恶心、又闷热、又脏、又臭，总之到处都是坏消息。你知道，我觉得亚利桑那州有一种现象，人们因为热爱阳光、热爱这里的生机而来到这里。你发现是这样吗，还是？我确实发现有一些人喜欢它。但当气温达到120度、125度（约48.9至51.7摄氏度）时，喜欢它的人就寥寥无几了。
Then they want to scurry inside where their air conditioning is, you know. We're out here 24-7. They get to go home in their nice, comfortable air conditioners. Bunny has hit on a central fact about life in modern Phoenix, which is that the heat affects people in profoundly unequal ways. For some, it's an asset. For some, it's an asset.
那时候他们就想急忙逃回有空调的室内，你知道的。而我们24小时都在外面。他们却可以回到舒适的空调房里。邦尼触及了现代凤凰城生活的一个核心事实，那就是酷热对人们的影响存在着极大的不平等。对某些人来说，这是一笔资产。对某些人来说，这是一笔资产。
For others, it's a liability. And this inequity goes back a long way in Phoenix's history. Nearly a thousand years ago, indigenous people found ways to live with the heat of the Sonoran Desert. They created cliff dwellings where the temperatures were cooler. They built homes with thick walls of stone and mud.
对其他人来说，这是一个负担。这种不平等在凤凰城的历史由来已久。将近一千年前，原住民就找到了适应索诺拉沙漠酷热的方法。他们建造了气温较低的悬崖住所。他们用厚厚的石头和泥土建造房屋。
And for centuries, the population of central Arizona stayed relatively small. The extreme heat provided a check on development, and Phoenix remained a sleepy outpost. But fast forward to the 1950s and 60s and that began to change. City boosters began selling Phoenix precisely because of its climate. They pitched it as a land without winter where you could play golf year round. And it turned out that hundreds of thousands of people
几个世纪以来，亚利桑那州中部的人口一直保持在相对较小的规模。极端的高温对城市发展起到了抑制作用，凤凰城一直是一个安静的前哨站。但快进到20世纪50和60年代，情况开始发生变化。城市推销员开始极力推销凤凰城，正是因为这里的天气。他们把它宣传为一个没有冬天的土地，在那里你可以全年打高尔夫球。事实证明，成千上万的人
wanted in on that vision. And if it got a little toasty in the summertime, there was a new-fangled technology that could help you with that. So you can find people in the early 60s talking about living, you know, completely air-conditioned lives. This is Andrew Needham, a historian who studies the environmental and indigenous history of the American West. And Andrew told me about this old article he found in the Saturday Evening Post.
都渴望实现这一愿景。如果夏天变得有点热，有一种新奇的技术可以帮你解决这个问题。所以你可以在60年代初的人们谈论过着，你知道的，完全空调化的生活。这是安德鲁·尼德姆（Andrew Needham），一位研究美洲西部环境与原住民历史的历史学家。安德鲁跟我讲了他在《星期六晚邮报》上发现的一篇旧文章。
It included an interview with a local banker. He boasted about how he got through the summer days. He says, well, I wake up in my air-conditioned room, I get in my air-conditioned car, I go to the air-conditioned garage of my building, I go to my air-conditioned office. At night, I go to an air-conditioned garage of my building. I go to my air-conditioned office. At night, I go to an air-conditioned restaurant. Maybe I see a movie in an air-conditioned theater.
其中包含对当地一位银行家的采访。他吹嘘自己是如何度过夏天的。他说，嗯，我在有空调的房间醒来，我坐进有空调的车里，我去我大楼有空调的车库，我去我有空调的办公室。到了晚上，我去我大楼有空调的车库。我去我有空调的办公室。到了晚上，我去有空调的餐厅。也许我会在有空调的影院看电影。
And so, you know, this kind of life entirely encased in the summer in refrigerated air conditioning is a reality for people like bankers. But while bankers were bathing in this mechanically cooled air, working-class people in Phoenix were living much hotter lives. Back in the 1960s, the city was starkly divided by race and class and by temperature. When a reporter from the New Republic went to Phoenix to write about the city,
所以，你知道，这种在夏天完全被冷气包裹的生活，对银行家这样的人来说是现实。但当银行家们沐浴在机械降温的空气中时，凤凰城的工人阶级过着热得多的生活。早在20世纪60年代，这座城市就因种族、阶层和温度而产生了鲜明的划痕。当《新共和国》杂志的一名记者前往凤凰城撰写关于该市的文章时，
He says something to the effect of two cities stare at each other from opposite sides of a golf course, essentially saying that like, here's this landscape of quality of life in which African American Latino people have all been concentrated in kind of deteriorating and dilapidated housing. That inferior housing had flimsier insulation and older electrical systems, which made it harder to cool. And poorer neighborhoods typically had more concrete, fewer trees, and denser development, all of which made the outdoor temperatures as much as 10 degrees hotter than in the wealthier parts of the city. wealthier parts of the city. Even as access to AC has expanded, poor people just have a harder time escaping the heat.
他说了一句大意是“两座城市在高尔夫球场两侧遥遥相望”的话，本质上是说，这里存在着一种生活品质的景观，而黑人和拉丁裔人群都被集中在不断恶化和破旧的住房中。这种劣质住房的隔热层更薄、电气系统更老旧，这使得降温更加困难。而且较贫穷的街区通常有更多的混凝土、更少的树木以及更密集的开发，所有这些都使得室外温度比富裕地区高出多达10度。富裕地区。尽管空调的普及率不断提高，但穷人要想避暑依然更加困难。
That was true decades ago, and it's still true today. Air conditioning is now nearly ubiquitous in Phoenix. Today, the vast majority of the city's buildings have AC. But paradoxically, the fact that it's everywhere also makes the city vulnerable. That's because most builders today don't build with heat in mind. You know, we've forgotten. Again, Jeff Goodell.
几十年前是这样，今天依然如此。如今，空调在凤凰城几乎无处不在。今天，该市绝大多数建筑都安装了空调。但矛盾的是，它无处不在这一事实也让这座城市变得脆弱。那是因为今天的绝大多数建筑商在建造时并没有把防暑纳入考虑。你知道，我们已经忘记了。再次引述杰夫·古德尔的话。
How to build buildings with natural ventilation. We've become dependent upon this machine, this cooling machine. Cooling modern buildings requires an enormous amount of electricity. And in a lot of places, including Phoenix, that energy still comes from fossil fuels. I didn't realize it, but air conditioning is responsible for about 4% of emissions globally, which is nearly double the amount from the entire airline industry. And that means that while we're cooling ourselves off, we're also making ourselves hotter. So you get into this sort of perpetuating cycle of more air conditioning, more burning
如何利用自然通风建造房屋。我们已经变得依赖这台机器，这台制冷机器。冷却现代建筑需要消耗巨大的电力。在包括凤凰城在内的许多地方，这些能源仍然来自化石燃料。我以前没有意识到，但空调产生的排放量约占全球排放量的4%，这几乎是整个航空业排放量的两倍。这意味着，在我们让自己凉爽下来的同时，我们也在让地球变得更热。所以你就会陷入这样一种恶性循环：更多的空调、更多的化石燃料燃烧，以及一个更热的地球。
of fossil fuels, and a hotter planet. And that vicious cycle can become deadly, because during an unprecedented heat wave, people crank the AC as high as it can go, which puts a lot of stress on the electrical grid and creates the potential for a catastrophic failure. It's like a sword of Damocles on a hotter planet. Air conditioning is great as long as it works. But if it fails, then we're all in big trouble.
这种恶性循环可能会致命，因为在史无前例的热浪期间，人们会将空调开到最大，这给电网带来了巨大的压力，并造成了发生灾难性故障的可能性。这就好比挂在一个更热地球之上的达摩克利斯之剑。只要空调能运转，它就棒极了。但如果它坏了，那我们全都要陷入大麻烦了。
When we come back, the worst case scenario. In Phoenix, air conditioning has become a fact of life. But what if the AC fails? This is the kind of scenario that keeps emergency planners up at night. And recently a study came out that provided them with ample nightmare fuel. The study modeled what would happen if a heat wave in Phoenix coincided with a grid failure and then a multi-day blackout. The results were like the source material for a new Mad Max movie.
广告回来后，我们将探讨最坏的情况。在凤凰城，空调已经成了生活的一部分。但如果空调坏了呢？这正是让应急规划人员夜不能寐的场景。最近，一项研究出炉了，为他们提供了充足的噩梦素材。该研究模拟了如果凤凰城的热浪与电网故障相重合，进而导致持续多日的停电，将会发生什么。其结果简直就像是一部新的《疯狂的麦克斯》电影的素材。
The study predicted that half the city's population, nearly 800,000 people, would need emergency room care. The city only has 3,000 emergency department beds. The study also showed that almost 13,000 people in Phoenix would die. All of us were kind of like, my goodness, this would be not ideal. This is Dr. Jeffrey Komp. He's an ER doctor at Valleywise Health, which serves Maricopa County. And I bet when he went to medical school,
该研究预测，全城一半的人口，即近80万名居民，将需要急诊室护理。而该市总共只有3000张急诊床位。研究还表明，凤凰城将有近13000人死亡。我们所有人都觉得，天哪，这可太不妙了。这是杰弗里·坎普医生（Dr. Jeffrey Komp）。他是马里科帕县瓦利怀斯健康医疗系统（Valleywise Health）的一名急诊科医生。我敢打赌，当他上医学院的时候，
he didn't think he'd be doing work on the front lines of climate change. But much like Sergio, that's exactly what he's doing. Every summer, Dr. Komp treats people coming into the ER with heat stroke. People even get contact burns from touching the metal side of a car or falling down on a hot sidewalk. But the summer of 2023 was different, touching the metal side of a car or falling down on a hot sidewalk.
他绝不会想到自己会站在应对气候变化的最前线。但就像塞尔吉奥一样，这正是他正在做的事情。每年夏天，坎普医生都会治疗因中暑而被送到急诊室的患者。人们甚至会因为触摸汽车金属侧面或在烫伤的人行道上摔倒而造成接触性烧伤。但2023年的夏天不同，触摸汽车金属侧面或在烫伤的人行道上摔倒。
But the summer of 2023 was different and maybe a sign of summers to come. It's been really hot. It's been really, really hot. And when we look at markers like mortality, so how many people die, it's much worse than last year. I spoke with Dr. Komp towards the end of last summer, and deaths were up 52% from the previous year. An estimated 645 people died from the heat in 2023, and almost 300 of them were unhoused. Dr. Komp says people were arriving at the ER in truly mind boggling conditions. Our thermometers top out at 109, and personally I've had multiple patients that have come
但2023年的夏天有所不同，这或许是未来夏天的预兆。天气真的太热了。天气真的、真的太热了。当我们看死亡率等指标（即有多少人死亡）时，情况比去年糟糕得多。我在去年夏天快结束时采访了坎普医生，当时死亡人数比前一年上升了52%。据估计，2023年有645人死于酷热，其中近300人是无家可归者。坎普医生说，送到急诊室的人状况简直匪夷所思。我们的温度计上限是109华氏度（约42.8摄氏度），就我个人而言，我有好几位患者送来时，
in that have maxed out our thermometers. So I honestly don't know what my, we call it T max or maximum temperature has been for patients but we've had people that come in incredibly, incredibly, incredibly hot. There are a couple different types of heat illness. The first is what's known as classic heat stroke, which happens when you're exposed to heat for a prolonged time. This kind of heat stroke tends to affect
体温已经爆表，超出了我们温度计的测量极限。所以我老实说不知道我的——我们称之为T max或最高体温——对于患者来说到底是多少，但我们确实遇到过体温高得难以置信、难以置信、难以置信的患者。中暑有几种不同的类型。第一种被称为经典性中暑，发生在你长时间暴露在高温下时。这种中暑往往影响
the more vulnerable of us, like babies and older folks, pregnant people and people with chronic heart conditions and hypertension. The second kind is called exertional heat stroke, and it can happen to really anybody, even very healthy people when they're doing intense physical activity. It could be a roofer or an athlete working out in the hot sun. As your body heats up, it reacts automatically, pumping more blood toward the surface of your skin where it can get cooler as you sweat. That's a normal
我们当中更脆弱的人，比如婴儿和老年人、孕妇以及患有慢性心脏病和高血压的人。第二种被称为劳力性中暑，它实际上可能发生任何人身上，甚至是身体非常健康的学在烈日下进行剧烈体力活动时。这可能是屋顶工人或在烈日下锻炼的运动员。当你的身体变热时，它会自动反应，将更多的血液泵向皮肤表面，这样你在出汗时就能散热。这是一个正常的
physical process, but if it's too hot outside, it starts to break down. If it's too hot, your blood can't cool off fast enough, so what starts to happen is your heart starts pounding faster and faster. Again, here's Jeff Goodell. Starts to kind of panic and think, okay, I need to cool off. We're not cooling off fast enough. I need to push more blood and more blood. In the case of heat stroke, this can become a runaway process where your body pulls blood away from your brain and internal organs,
生理过程，但如果外面太热，它就会开始崩溃。如果天气太热，你的血液就无法冷却得足够快，所以开始发生的情况是你的心脏开始跳得越来越快。再次引用杰夫·古德尔的话。开始感到有些恐慌并心想：“好吧，我需要降温。我们降温不够快。我需要推动更多的血液，更多的血液。”在发生中暑的情况下，这可能变成一个失控的过程，你的身体将血液从大脑和内脏器官抽离，
desperately pumping it towards your skin to try and cool it down. And if you don't start cooling off, then your body temperature starts rising and rising. And once it gets above 103 or 104 degrees, which is only five, six degrees above the normal body temperature, then you start to get into real serious problems where the actual cell membranes in your body, especially in your internal organs, begin to actually melt. And your body kind of, I know it sounds like a terrible thing to say, but it's true, it kind of liquefies from the inside. In most DRs, the standard care for heatstroke is something called active cooling. That means misting the patient or covering them with a cool wet sheet and blowing fans on them.
拼命将其泵向皮肤以试图降温。如果你不开始降温，那么你的体温就会持续不断地上升。一旦超过103或104华氏度（约39.4至40摄氏度，仅比正常体温高出五六度），你就会陷入真正严重的危机中——体内，尤其是内脏器官中的实际细胞膜开始真正融化。你的身体有点——我知道这听起来是个很可怕的说法，但这是真的——它在内部发生某种程度的液化。在大多数急诊室，中暑的标准治疗方法被称为主动降温。这意味着向患者喷水雾或用凉爽的湿床单覆盖他们并用风扇吹他们。
But when you're seeing a lot of patients come in with really severe heat stroke, then you start getting creative. We're one of the only hospitals that does a whole body cold water immersion therapy for all of our heat strokes. So this is our EMS entrance. As a patient is coming in, especially if they're coming in from a pre-hospital or EMS, they're gonna be coming and wheeling right through here as if they're going to our resuscitation rooms. Dr. Komp demonstrated what happens
但当你看到大量患者患有极其严重的中暑时，你就会开始发挥创造力。我们是少数几家为所有中暑患者进行全身冷水浸泡疗法的医院之一。所以这是我们的急救中心入口。当患者送进来时，特别是如果他们是从院前急救或急救医疗服务（EMS）转送过来的，他们会被直接推进来，就好像要去我们的复苏室一样。坎普医生演示了
when a patient gets rushed in with suspected heat stroke. What they do is they wheel the patient into a room where they do the first round of resuscitations, and then they place the patient in a giant plastic body bag and pack ice in around them. And unfortunately, I need a better term, but we're just zipping people into body bags. Filling it up with ice and water and then zipping them back up.
当有疑似中暑患者被紧急送入时会发生什么。他们做的是把患者推入一间屋子，在那里进行第一轮复苏，然后把患者装进一个巨大的塑料尸袋里，并在周围塞满冰块。不幸的是，我需要一个更好的词，但我们就是在把人拉上拉链装进尸袋里。装满冰块和水，然后把拉链拉上。
But making sure that we're keeping arms and frankly the face and airway exposed so we can continue with vital signs and getting IV access but also continuing to monitor our patient status. Sometimes if patients are treated fast enough, they recover. But even people who survive can have organ damage and neurological problems that stay with them. It's sad because this is an absolutely preventable disease. I mean, different people are affected based on different risk factors,
但要确保我们的手臂、坦率地说还有脸部和气道保持暴露，以便我们可以继续监测生命体征并建立静脉通路，同时也继续监测我们的患者状态。有时，如果患者得到足够快的治疗，他们会恢复。但即使是幸存下来的人，也可能会留下伴随终身的器官损伤和神经系统问题。这很悲哀，因为这是一种完全可以预防的疾病。我的意思是，不同的人受到的影响取决于不同的风险因素、
different underlying medical problems, other intoxications and drug use. But for the most part, if we can get someone out of the heat, we can prevent a lot of death. There's a brutal simplicity to who is most at risk for heat stroke. It's the people who have trouble escaping the heat because they don't have air conditioning or it's broken or too expensive to run or they're older and have health issues and live alone or
不同的潜在医疗问题、其他药物滥用和吸毒情况。但就大多数情况而言，如果我们能把某人带离酷热环境，我们就能预防大量的死亡。谁最容易面临中暑风险，这里面有一种残酷的简单性。是那些难以躲避酷热的人——因为他们没有空调，或者空调坏了、太贵开不起，或者他们年纪大了、有健康问题且独居，或者
they're struggling with addiction and are vulnerable to passing out in the sun or they live outside. All of which means that vulnerability to heat is tied up with big structural problems that can be hard to solve, like homelessness, addiction, poverty, and housing. Keeping people safe from heat is both easy, just give them a place to cool down, and hard. and hard. Do you currently or have you ever had a case manager helping you towards housing? I'm back in the Circle K parking lot with Sergio Armandades. He's the outreach worker with the Phoenix Rescue Mission. And now he's chatting up a guy named Jason Joseph, who ticks the boxes for many of the risk factors I just listed.
他们正在与毒瘾作斗争，很容易在太阳下晕倒，或者他们露宿街头。所有这一切都意味着，对热浪的脆弱性与难以解决的重大结构性问题紧密相连，比如无家可归、吸毒、贫困和住房问题。保护人们免受酷热侵害既容易（只需给他们一个降温的地方），又困难。又困难。你目前或曾经有案主经理协助你寻找住房吗？我又回到了Circle K的停车场，和塞尔吉奥·阿尔曼达斯在一起。他是“凤凰城救援使命”的外展工作人员。现在他正在和一个名叫杰森·约瑟夫（Jason Joseph）的人闲聊，这个人符合我刚才列出的许多风险因素。
How has this summer been for you, kind of heat-wise? A couple days were ridiculous, like, I thought I was gonna die. On one of the hottest days, when temperatures were up near 120, Jason undertook his own improvised cold water immersion. He headed over to a nearby ditch, and despite the terrible smell of the water, he jumped in. I was so glad for that. All I could do is lay in the shade soaking wet, and then it'd get so hot,
就温度而言，今年夏天对你来说怎么样？有几天简直荒谬至极，我觉得自己快死了。在最热的日子之一，当温度接近120华氏度（约48.9摄氏度）时，杰森采取了自己即兴的冷水浸泡。他走向附近的一条沟渠，尽管水散发着可怕的气味，他还是跳了进去。我太庆幸有那个了。我能做的就是全身湿透地躺在阴凉处，然后天气变得太热了，
I had to go back in the ravine and then go back to the shade. It's like you just spent the whole day like that. Just cooling, I couldn't do anything else that day. I had to just cool. The mission was maintaining. Cause a lot of the places you'd think, oh, why don't you just go inside somewhere? But they would kick me out anywhere cause I was dirty
我不得不回到沟壑里，然后再回到阴凉处。就像你一整天都在那样度过。只有降温，那天我什么也做不了。我不得不去降温。使命在维持。因为很多地方你都会想，“哦，你为什么不去某个室内呢？”但他们会把我赶出去，因为我很脏，
and you know, my hair all messed up. And they're just like, no, get out of here. MUSIC Jason survived that day, but from talking to him, it sounds like every day in July and August required a kind of desperate improvisation to cool himself down one way or another, like stumbling on an air-conditioned church
你知道的，我的头发乱七八糟的。他们就会说：“不，滚出去。”音乐 杰森那天活了下来，但从跟他的交谈中听起来，7月和8月的每一天都需要某种绝望的即兴发挥来让自己以某种方式降温，比如跌跌撞撞地闯进一家不会把他赶出去的带空调的教堂，或者找到一处有微风吹拂的阴凉角落。坐在塞尔吉奥的车里，你能听到空调又在运转了。通常情况下，作为一名广播制作人，我会要求交谈对象关掉空调，以便更清晰地录制他们的声音。但在凤凰城，我是绝对不会这么做的。当我们开车前往一个新的地点时，塞尔吉奥向我讲述了他最近的一次经历。他当时正坐在一个公园里。
that wouldn't turn him away, or finding a little piece of shade where a breeze would pass over him. Back in the car with Sergio, you can hear the AC running again. Normally, as a radio producer, I would ask the person I'm talking with to turn it off so that I could record their voice more clearly. But there is no way I'm doing that in Phoenix. And as we drive on to a new location, Sergio tells me about an experience he had recently. He was sitting in a park.
我坐在那儿，看到有警察，地上好像躺着一具尸体。所以我心里犯嘀咕，那是尸体吗？我看不出来。最终，警察在那个人形周围拉起了黄色的警戒线。然后我意识到那确实是一具尸体。我忍不住去想那个人，你知道吗？比如，他是怎么死的？是中暑吗？是吸毒吗？还是两者都有？塞尔吉奥提出的那些问题：他是怎么死的？是中暑吗？是吸毒吗？结果发现，有一个人专门负责寻找这些答案。所以我是杰夫·约翰斯顿医生（Dr. Jeff Johnston）。我是马里科帕县的首席法医。
And I'm sitting there and I see that there's police and it looks like a body on the ground. And so I'm just kind of wondering like, is that a body? I can't tell. Eventually, the police strung yellow tape around the figure. And then I realized it is a body. And I just couldn't help but wonder about that person, you know? Like, how did they die? Was it the heat? Was it drugs? Was it a mixture? The questions that Sergio is asking, how did they die? Was it the heat? Was it drugs? It turns out there's a person whose job it is to find the answers. So I'm Dr. Jeff Johnston. I'm the chief medical examiner for Maricopa County.
作为首席法医，约翰斯顿医生监管着一个120人的团队。他们负责调查该县发生的非自然死亡事件，包括热浪可能是一个因素的死亡。约翰斯顿医生在谈论他的工作时表现出一种卸下防备的坦率，他提到夏季月份的方式可能会永远留在我的记忆中。马太福音 10 说真的，我们确实把这当作一起大规模伤亡事件来对待。
As the chief medical examiner, Dr. Johnston oversees a staff of 120 people. They're responsible for investigating the non-natural deaths that happen in the county, including the ones where heat might be a factor. Dr. Johnston speaks with a disarming directness about his work, and the way he referred to the summer months will probably stay with me forever. Matthew 10 Really, we do look at this like a mass fatality event.
贝丝·多姆布科夫斯基（Beth Dombkowski） 大规模伤亡事件。这是一个我通常与枪击事件或恐怖袭击联系在一起的词。但他说的只是6月、7月和月。马太福音 10 你会发现死亡人数突然激增，你必须对超出常规资源的情况展开调查。弄清楚一个人是否死于与热相关的死因，实际上比你想象的要困难得多。尽管热射病对身体具有毁灭性的破坏性，但它在尸检中并没有什么具体的
Beth Dombkowski A mass fatality event. It's a phrase I associate with shootings or acts of terrorism. But he's just talking about June, July, and August. Matthew 10 Where you have a sudden surge in the number of deaths that you've got to investigate that outstrip your typical resources. Figuring out whether a person died from heat-related causes is actually harder than you might think. Despite its devastating effects on the body, heat stroke doesn't really have a specific
物理特征。高温引起的死亡看起来非常像器官衰竭或单纯的机体腐烂。因此，了解发现遗体时的背景环境是关键。为了做到这一点，该部门雇用了40名法医死因调查员。他们前往现场收集信息。空调是否在运转，他们是否有水和食物，在现场收集这些温度信息、其他风险因素的迹象，这些都有助于我们的法医病理学家对死因或促成
physical signature that shows up in an autopsy. Heat-induced death looks a lot like organ failure or just general decay. And so, understanding the context in which the body was found is key. To do that, the department employs 40 medical legal death investigators. They go out to scenes to collect information. Whether the air conditioner is working, whether they've got access to food, water, collecting information at the scene, those temperatures, other signs of risk factors that help our forensic pathologists to make the correct conclusion about what caused or contributed
死亡的因素做出正确的结论。去年夏天，约翰斯顿的调查员团队遇到的现场都很艰难。他们发现蜷缩在帐篷里、伸展在柏油路上、瘫倒在后院里，或者被困在空调坏掉、室内温度飙升至130华氏度（约54.4摄氏度）的房屋里的尸体。每个人都处于极限状态。办公室处理的尸体如此之多，以至于他们不得不紧急调来额外的冷藏拖车作为备用存储。
to the death. Last summer, the scenes that Johnston's team of investigators encountered were difficult. They found bodies curled up in tents, stretched out on the asphalt, slumped in backyards, or entombed in houses where the air conditioning had broken and the temperatures inside had soared to 130 degrees. Everyone was stretched to capacity. The office was dealing with so many bodies that they had to call in for extra refrigerated trailers for backup storage.
他们本可以引进更多病理学家，但根本没有。这看起来不是一份通过简单扩编就能解决的工作，你知道我的意思吗？你的技能太专业了，凤凰城周围可能不会有一堆临时的法医闲逛。确实，是的。如果我们有空缺，平均需要20个月才能填补。全国各地的所有办公室都在为此苦苦挣扎，并且已经持续了将近二十年。
And they would have brought in more pathologists, but there weren't any. It doesn't seem like an easy job to just staff up, you know what I mean? Your skills are so specialized, there's probably not just a bunch of like temp medical examiners hanging around Phoenix. Definitely, yeah. If we have a vacancy, it's on average 20 months for us to be able to fill it. All offices across the country are really struggling with that and have been for the better part of two decades.
所以你可以把病理学家加入我们已经不堪重负、在气候变化重压下摇摇欲坠的基础设施名单中。我们的住房不达标，我们的保险系统没有准备好。我们的道路、桥梁和堤坝正在老化且不堪一击。而我们的法医非常、非常疲惫。凤凰城的热浪日益显现为一场可预测的年度灾难。但令人惊异的是，联邦政府并不这么看。极端高温并不在FEMA（联邦紧急事务管理局）有权应对的灾难名单之列。人们对热浪的风险和危险存在着巨大的低估，
So you can add pathologists to the list of our already overburdened infrastructure buckling under the weight of climate change. Our housing is inadequate, our insurance systems aren't ready. Our roads and bridges and levees are aging and flimsy. And our medical examiners are very, very tired. Heat in Phoenix increasingly appears to be a predictable annual disaster. But amazingly, that's not the way the federal government sees it. Extreme heat is not on the list of disasters that FEMA is authorized to respond to. There's been a vast underestimation of the risks of heat and the dangers of heat that
以至于连FEMA的人都还落后于形势，没有重新评估我们所生活的这个新气候世界的风险。这部分是因为许多热浪的受害者仍然不为人见。全国乃至全球各地与热浪相关死亡的数据依然不够充分。而且热浪杀死了许多生活在社会边缘的人。他们并不是那些大声疾呼要求获得更多保护的人。但这也是因为我们的政府看待灾难的基本方式。它是面向对物品的破坏，而不是对人的伤害。
even the people at FEMA are still behind the curve in recalculating the risks of this new climate world that we're living in. And that's partly because so many of HEAT's victims are still unseen. The data on HEAT-related deaths across the country and around the world remains inadequate. And HEAT kills a lot of people who are living on the margins. They're not the people that are out there lobbying for more protection. But it's also because of the fundamental way that our government thinks about disasters. It's geared towards damage to stuff rather than damage to people.
在灾难发生后权衡如何发放资金时，政府绝大多数将财产价值作为衡量标准。从某些方面来看，这种计算是有道理的。调查与热相关的死亡事件既困难又耗时。当你谈论超负荷的社工、苦于应付庞大患者群体的医疗系统，或者当一个人在滚烫的人行道上白白死去时所失去的东西时，很难将损失量化。但这意味着凤凰城以及全国各地的炎热地区，每年夏天在热浪夺走可怕的人命时，基本上只能靠自己。
The government overwhelmingly uses property value as a metric when weighing how to dish out funds after disasters happen. And in some ways, that calculation makes sense. It's hard and time-consuming to investigate heat-related deaths. And it's hard to quantify damage when you're talking about overstretched social workers, or a hospital system struggling to keep up with its patient load, or what's lost when a person needlessly dies
杰夫·古德尔有时将空调称为“遗忘的技术”。我们让自己凉爽下来的能力，掩盖了我们周围的世界正在变得
on a hot sidewalk. But that means that places like Phoenix, and hot places across the country, are largely left to fend for themselves every summer, when heat is extracting a terrible human toll. Jeff Goodell sometimes calls air conditioning a technology of forgetting. The ability to cool ourselves down obscures the fact that the world around us is getting
更加炎热和危险的事实。就连曾在凤凰城街头流落五年的塞尔吉奥·阿尔曼达斯，有时也会忘记那段经历是什么样的。他和同样曾无家可归的妻子有时会开玩笑说，他们变得多么娇气，每当盛夏时节空调无法让屋里更凉快一点时，他们就会抱怨。所以我当时想，我们怎么了？我们过去在外面可像黑帮一样硬气，把一切都当成浮云。现在我们却只为75华氏度（约23.9摄氏度）的空调抱怨。
much hotter and more dangerous. Even Sergio Armandades, who lived on the streets of Phoenix for five years, sometimes forgets what that experience was like. He and his wife, who was also homeless, will joke about how soft they've gotten, how they complain when the AC can't get their house any cooler on the hottest summer days. So I'm like, what happened to us? We used to be gangster out there just dealing with it like nothing. And now we're just complaining about 75 degree AC.
这真是，天哪。在这个完整故事的背景中，一直盘旋着一个问题。再过20年、50年或100年，凤凰城还会是一个适宜居住的地方吗？这是我在采访中多次提出的一个问题，大多数人并不喜欢被问到这个问题。人们会出于许多充分的理由继续住在凤凰城，比如工作、住房和家庭。但同样真实的是，在90年代初的典型年份里，凤凰城经历的
It's like, geez. There's a question hovering in the background of this whole story. Will Phoenix be a livable place in another 20 or 50 or 100 years? This was a question I posed a few times in interviews, and most people did not appreciate being asked about it. People will continue living in Phoenix for a lot of good reasons, like jobs and housing and family. But it's also true that in a typical year, back in the early 90s, Phoenix experienced
每年气温超过110华氏度（约43.3摄氏度）的日子大约有7天。去年，即2023年，当统计完所有日子时，这座城市经历了55天的高温天气。是的，凤凰城现在正在做许多重要的适应工作。该市创建了全美第一个由公共资金资助的热浪应对办公室。他们正在用海运集装箱建造新的带空调的无家可归者庇护所，防暑准备工作全年都在进行。但我们的适应能力是有限度的。我们并不确切知道这些极限在哪里。我们不知道自己究竟何时会触及它们。这很大程度上取决于你愿意
about 7 days above 110 degrees annually. Last year, in 2023, by the time all the days were tallied, the city saw 55 days at those temperatures. And yes, Phoenix is doing a lot of important adaptation work right now. The city created the first publicly funded heat response office in the whole country. They're building new air-conditioned homeless shelters out of shipping containers, and preparation for summer happens year round. But there are limits to our ability to adapt. We don't know exactly where those limits are. We don't know exactly when we'll hit them. It depends a lot on what you're willing
忍受什么。只要有足够的资金和技术，你就可以住在火星上，对吧？我的意思是，你可以那样生活。但你愿意住在一个当你走到外面时——
to endure. With enough money and enough technology, you could live on Mars, right? I mean, you can live that way. But do you want to live in a place where when you go outside You can't touch the steering wheel on your car if you fall on the sidewalk you get third-degree burns Where animals are dying because it's so hot where people on the street are Literally dying on the streets because it is so hot I mean, is that the kind of world you want to live in? Not me.
你摸不了车方向盘，如果你摔在人行道上就会受到三度烧伤，动物因为太热而死去，街头的人们因为太热而活活渴死在街头的地方吗？我的意思是，那是你想生活的世界吗？我才不想。
I'd move. But in the meantime, people are arriving in Phoenix, not leaving. It's still one of the fastest growing cities in the whole country. For at least six months a year, the weather is still glorious. People still want to live in the land without winter. And at least for now, many are finding ways to make it work. The people I spoke with in Phoenix were like messengers from the future, spelling out a vision of what our hotter world might look like. And that hotter world looks nocturnal.
我会搬走。但与此同时，人们还在涌入菲尼克斯，而不是离开。它依然是整个国家发展最快的城市之一。一年中至少有六个月，天气依然晴朗壮丽。人们仍然想住在没有冬天的土地上。至少目前看来，许多人正在找到适应这一切的方法。我在菲尼克斯交谈过的人，就像来自未来的信使，向我们展示了我们这个更炎热的世界将会是什么样子。而那个更炎热的世界，将是夜行性的。
Everywhere in the summer, people shift their lives towards the early morning and late evening when temperatures are cooler. People hike at night with headlamps. The zoo opens at 6 a.m. so that kids can enjoy it before the real heat kicks in and all the animals hide. And from April to September there are a series of trail races called the Insomniac Night Runs, which start in the evening and continue through the night on desert trails surrounding the city.
夏天，无论何处，人们的生活都转向了气温较低的清晨和深夜。人们戴着头灯在夜间徒步。动物园早上6点开门，以便孩子们能在真正的酷暑来临、所有动物都藏起来之前好好游玩。从4月到9月，有一系列被称为“失眠者夜跑”的越野赛，它们在傍晚开始，并穿过城市周围的沙漠小径，一直持续到深夜。
It's a real scene, with music and beer served at the finish line and runners high-fiving their friends. This particular race is happening at the McDowell Mountain Regional Park, about 45 minutes from downtown Phoenix. The trail winds through a Sonoran desert landscape, and it's gorgeous here. I can imagine the runners racing under the stars, past prickly pears and saguaros, some of them wilting from the heat. I imagine that even in the dark, the runners are guzzling water and stuffing ice in their shirts and shorts to keep cool. They're finding ways to keep doing this thing they love, in a place they love, despite the immense challenge of it.
这是一个真正的热闹场景，终点线提供音乐和啤酒，跑者们与朋友击掌相庆。这场特定的比赛在距离菲尼克斯市中心约45分钟车程的麦克道尔山区域公园举行。小径蜿蜒穿过索诺拉沙漠景观，这里美极了。我可以想象跑者们在繁星下奔跑，掠过仙人掌和巨柱仙人掌，其中一些人正因高温而萎靡不振。我能想象，即使在黑暗中，跑者们仍在猛灌水，把冰块塞进衬衫和短裤里以降温。尽管面临巨大的挑战，他们仍在寻找方法，继续做他们热爱的事，在他们热爱的地方。
Trying to get their miles in before the sun rises and a new, even hotter day begins. The thing about the big story of climate change is that we're only in the first chapter. Here's Emmett again. We're only just starting to feel the magnitude of the changes we've unleashed and how they will cascade into nearly every aspect of our lives. For some people, climate change has already been disastrous.
他们试图在太阳升起、全新且更热的一天开始之前跑完他们的里程。关于气候变化这个宏大故事，关键在于我们才刚刚翻开第一章。埃mett又出现了。我们才刚刚开始感受到我们所释放的变化的规模，以及它们将如何波及我们生活的几乎方方面面。对有些人来说，气候变化已经是灾难性的。
It has destroyed homes and uprooted lives. For others, the changes have been subtler. But the signs are all there, lurking in our rearranged running schedules, in our insurance statements, and our air conditioning bills. This isn't the apocalypse, just a series of unravelings. And while we're all busy worrying about the end of the world, the world is just changing beneath our feet and leaving us behind. There's a lot that we can do to try and catch up.
它摧毁了家园，颠覆了生活。对其他人来说，变化则更微妙。但迹象无处不在，潜伏在我们重新安排的跑步日程中、我们的保险单里，以及我们的空调账单里。这不是世界末日，只是一系列解体。正当所有人都在忙着担心世界末日的时候，世界却在我们的脚下悄然改变，将我们抛在身后。为了迎头赶上，我们能做的事情还有很多。
We can run at night and replace our wooden floorboards. We can keep people cool and give the river more room to meander. And unlike a cactus, we can move out of harm's way. None of that will be easy. And when you do a lot of stories about adapting to climate change, you can't help but come away feeling like we need to do everything in our power
我们可以夜跑，更换木质地板。我们可以为人们降温，给河流留出更多蜿蜒的空间。与仙人掌不同，我们可以搬到安全的地方。这一切都不容易。当你做了大量关于适应气候变化的报道后，你禁不住会产生一种感觉：我们需要竭尽全力
not to make this hard job harder on ourselves. We need to stop the forces that are irrevocably changing our planet. And at the same time, be honest about the degree to which our planet has already been changed. When I'm feeling anxious about the uncertainty of the world right now, which is often, I find myself yearning for a feeling of stability
不要让我们本已艰难的工作变得更加困难。我们需要阻止那些正在不可逆转地改变我们星球的力量。与此同时，也要坦诚面对我们的星球已经被改变的程度。当我为当今世界的充满不确定性感到焦虑时——这种情况经常发生，我发现自己开始渴望一种稳定感
that I really only felt during my own childhood, living my quaint little life in my quaint little Vermont town. I find myself wanting to go back there, to a mild July day, skipping rocks in the gentle flow of the Winooski, or curled up with a novel in the back of the creaky old bookstore. That river still exists, and that bookstore still exists, but they're in a different world now. We all are. And the task ahead is to embrace the hard work of living in the world as it is. This episode of Not Built For This was reported and produced by Delaney Hall and me, Emmett
这种感觉我只在自己的童年时期体验过，当时我在佛蒙特州那个古朴的小镇上过着古朴的小生活。我发现自己想回到那里，回到一个温和的七月天，在温努斯基河温柔的水流中打水漂，或者在吱呀作响的老书店后面蜷缩着看小说。那条河依然存在，那家书店也依然存在，但它们现在身处一个不同的世界了。我们所有人都是。接下来的任务是拥抱在现状世界中生活的艰辛工作。本期《不适宜此地》（Not Built For This）由德兰妮·霍尔和我（埃mett
Fitzgerald. The rest of the Not Built For This team is producers Jason DeLeon and Sophie Kottner. Further invaluable editing from Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and Roman Mars. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez. Theme and original music by George Langford from Actual Magic, with additional music by Swan Rayal. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Series art by Aaron Nestor. Special thanks to everyone Delaney spoke with for this episode who didn't make it into the story.
菲茨杰拉德）共同采访和制作。《不适宜此地》团队的其他成员包括制作人杰森·德莱昂和索菲·科特纳。克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆和罗曼·马尔斯提供了宝贵的编辑指导。混音和声音设计由马丁·甘萨尔负责。主题曲和原创音乐由来自Actual Magic的乔治·兰格福德创作，斯旺·雷亚尔提供额外音乐。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦基安负责。系列美术由亚伦·内斯特设计。特别感谢德兰妮在本期节目中采访过但未能入选该故事的所有人。
That includes Juanita Constable of the NRDC, Dr. Rebecca Sunenshine, the medical director at the Maricopa County Department of Public Health, Masabi Perea, the deputy director of Chispa, Arizona, Phoenix Mayor Kate Gallego, Go Chargers, and finally to Alvaro Morella. Also a special thank you to all of the other people who helped us with this whole series at various points in the process. Anna Weber, Ian Gray, ZJ Taylor, Hamilton Nolan, Dustin Mulvaney, Alice Hill, Margaret Alicia Garcia,
这包括自然资源保护委员会（NRDC）的胡安妮塔·康斯塔布尔、马里科帕县公共卫生局医疗主任丽贝卡·森恩辛博士、亚利桑那州奇斯帕（Chispa）副主任马萨比·佩雷亚、菲尼克斯市长凯特·加莱戈（加油充电队！），最后感谢阿尔瓦罗·莫雷拉。还要特别感谢在整个过程的不同阶段为这个系列提供帮助的所有其他人：安娜·韦伯、伊恩·格雷、ZJ·泰勒、汉密尔顿·诺兰、达斯汀·穆尔瓦尼、爱丽丝·希尔、玛格丽特·艾丽西亚·加西亚、
John Liotti, Jake Metcalf, Meg Boranski-Alasago, and Mike Herzog, Alex Kolker, Richie Blink, The Coalition to Restore Coastal Louisiana, The Anthropocene Alliance, Alexis Kofit of Soulfood Farm, Virginia Hanashchik, and Susan Sakeash. Thank you to all of our partners and families for putting up with the long hours working on this. And finally, our immense thanks to 99PI boss Roman Mars for giving us the time and the space to create this series. Not Built for This was a six-part series from 99% Invisible. This is our final episode. Thank you so much for listening. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is our digital director.
约翰·利奥蒂、杰克·梅特卡夫、梅格·博兰斯基-阿拉萨戈、迈克·赫尔佐格、亚历克斯·科尔克、里奇·布林克、恢复路易斯安那州海岸联盟、人类世联盟、心灵食物农场的亚历克西斯·科菲特、弗吉尼亚·哈纳什奇克和苏珊·萨基什。感谢我们所有的合作伙伴和家人，容忍我们为之付出的大量工作时间。最后，我们要向99PI的老板罗曼·马尔斯致以无限的谢意，感谢他给予我们时间和空间来创作这个系列。《不适宜此地》是来自《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）的一个六集系列节目。这是我们的最后一集。非常感谢您的收听。卡西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特ッド是我们的数字总监。
The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Barube, Vivian Le, Lasha Madan, Gabriella Gladney, Jacob Maldonado Medina, and Nina Potuck. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. You can find 99% Invisible on all of the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that and every episode of 99PI
99PI团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、维维安·勒、拉沙·马丹、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳和尼娜·波图克。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分。您可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新Discord服务器上找到《99%隐形》。那里有一个链接，通往每个单集的99PI
and not built for this at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及《不适宜此地》，网址是99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。